we have a voicemail number it's to 192
david p a lot of people pat angry that i
do not watch and have never watched a
full episode of game of thrones one
person happy about it
it's the Eggman dave there are a lot of
things about you that I totally love the
thing I love the most is that you've
never seen a game of Thrones program so
I haven't either you're good man ok that
was it yeah I got a ton of email from
people saying David you need to
understand that there's so many lessons
to be learned from Game of Thrones
politically socially culturally etc and
my response continues to be I don't have
HBO yeah I I feel like the Eggman
respects you because you know you're
talking about when it comes to politics
and economics and and all these
different topics but really this whole
time he respected you more for what you
didn't know which is that you haven't
even seen Game of Thrones that's right
and I don't even know like I heard
something about Ed Sheeran like was that
Sharon in an episode or is there a
character that looks like I'd sure I
genuinely have no idea I don't know
what's going on with Game of Thrones
would you be surprised if the Eggman
calls back in in like a month's time and
says you have to watch Game of Thrones
because he got sucked in yeah I would
not be noting the Eggman would
potentially do would surprise me okay
we've got another non-scientist put in
place of a science agency this time it's
NASA I will talk about some small
changes that everybody can do to reduce
waste in their daily life but what I
really want to get at is whether these
changes are so small as to be
insignificant and we will also talk
about Elon Musk's very dire predictions
about World War 3 and it has according
to him nothing to do with Kim jong-un or
North Korea or anything of the sort it
has to do with something very very
different and we'll talk about that on
the bonus show how do you get access to
the bonus show there are now soon to be
multiple ways number one old faithful
membership you sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership you can get
$1 trial membership at david pakman.com
slash dollar with peace and love try it
out you get the bonus show soon I would
predict within seven to ten days the
bonus show will also be a
patreon benefits at the five-dollar
patron level patreon.com slash david
pakman show so anyway more on that later
this week early next week we'll talk to
you on the bonus show